.
- Good girl! Good girl!
- Après avoir funtntntntntntntnt
installées ici, à Léry,
à l'ouest de Montréal où
la guerre ne pourrait pas
sembler plus lointaine.
alement, après
deux mois de stress", dit Olga.
Elle se préparait à aller
au travail le jour où la guerre
a commen
"Tous nos plans d'avenir
envolés à ce moment, explique
Anastasiia. Notre vie a
complètement chaviré."
NORMAND THÉRIEN
- Ça se passe très bien. Ce sons
à rencontrer, à discuter...
Elles sont ouvertes. Il n'y aIER
- Elles sont... je suis
.. je suis aussi émotive
qu'Olga, mais elles sont
exceptionnelles. Regarde moi.
(rires)rmand,
un couple de retraités,
les accueillent cheillent cheils
les chambres que leurs enfants
occupaient autrefois.
- Le jour un, Anastasiia je l'ae
qu'elle voulait déjà que je
regarde son CV.
- Elle t Kiev, alo Kiev, alo Kia
était professeure de philologie
versité.
les deux vont se trouver
un travail à la hauteur
de leurs compétences.
- Victoriia, elle, était
dentiste en Ukraine. Arrivée
elle a déjà été engagée dans
cette clinique dentaire
de Châteauguay.
e des premiers
bombardements quand son mari l'a
Il voulait partir tout
de suite. Elle n'est jamais
retournée chez elle.
À la maison avec leurs deux
jumeaux, le mari de Victoriia,
retrouve, tranquillement,
une certaine normalité.
"Les enfants s'adaptent trèsbit
la garderie." Oui, il y a
des moments difficiles, mais
ici. Barbara et Wayne, qui
les hébergent depuis quelques
jours, les considèrent déjà
comme de la famille.
"On fait nos premiers pas.
Au débutmprenait rien,
avoue Maksym, mais on commence
à se débrouiller."
Et qUzHYzÑHk/Yle vie
au Québec, dit, justement,- Bie.
Je suis contente.
- Olga, sa fille Anastasiia et
Maksym assistent tous à leurcomt
de réfugiés ukrainiens.t...
- Comment.....
- ...tu...
- ...t'appelles?
ines,
ils seront ici du lundi
au vendredi, la t
les cahiers d'apprentissage.
- Comment tu t'appelles?
- J'avais plusieur
qui arrivaient sur le territoire
du même coup.d'accueil et de fon
en immigration du Roussillon,
s'est chargée de l'inscription
des nouveaux étudiants.
Des dizaines d'autres n'ont pas
à l'aut
NICOLETA CARAULAN, coordo.,
Service, immigration Roussil
la langue passe l'intégration.
Si je ne connais pas la lang
pour moi ça va être complètement
impossible ou totalement
difficile de m'int
- B...
- C...- D...- D...- D...- D...-.
- D...- Maîtriser le français
les aidera à trouver un emploi.
le ministre du Travail indique
exprimé le souhait d'engager
des ressortissants ukrainiens.
JEAN BOULET, ministre du Travair
la guerre, par l'invasion russe.
- Repartir à zéro demande
beaucoup d'efforts; se refairea.
tres sont
prêts à vous aider, c'est un peu
plus facile.
créées non seulement par
les pays
les gens.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Lér